that was super [__] depressed like in
the drug use comparing myself to friends
they're making like 100k a month I
couldn't even like hold a job pretty
much like four months I almost killed
myself like almost ended it but I said
[__] that and so like now I'm working on
two business ideas I'm just trying to
turn everything around like exercise
like just get my [__] together
um and I'm really like happy that I'm
like in a better mental space now what
got you to that place was pure Envy in
comparison it was 100 bro you don't know
what's going on in my life don't envy
anybody you have no idea what's going on
with anybody in this place it may look
good it might be attractive they might
have a [__] Rolex yeah you don't know
what's in their [__] soul that's what
it was I would like want to be happy but
just maybe more and more depressing I
was just going farther and farther down
with every accomplishment other people
had no bro nobody's accomplishments have
anything to do with you I'm happy you're
getting out of it bro I appreciate it